They're here.
Digital vaccine passports are rolling out for healthcare workers in the north of England.
It's the work of British company V-Health Passport.
What's the advantage of having this digitally?
Why not just give everyone a piece of paper?
People are starting to sell fake COVID passports so they can go on airlines.
We're using the VCode because it is end-to-end secure.
It ensures that none of these certificates, either paper or digital, can be forged.
They're far from alone.
IBM, Microsoft, even the Danish government are all working on their own versions...
...of a digital vaccine passport to reopen borders...
...and allow people to travel without quarantines.
IATA, The International Air Transport Association,...
...which is piloting its own vaccine passport,...
...says the biggest hurdle isn't the technology at all...
...but the lack of clear standards from governments and the World Health Organization..